all right this weekend an Epic movie
adventure begins as a fantasy
role-playing game with Legions of loyal
fans comes to life we are talking of
course about Dungeons and Dragons honor
among Thieves actor Chris Pine leads the
Band of Thieves turned unlikely Heroes
he's playing Jack Ryan and well he's
played Jack Ryan and Captain Kirk making
a name for himself of course as the star
of these major film franchises and he's
hoping to do it yet again Natalie
Morales caught up with pine in Los
Angeles
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
puts an adventurous Twist on the popular
fantasy role-playing game but given the
fan loyalty Chris Pine was a little
hesitant when it came to taking on the
starring role of Edgar Darvis I got the
script and I was like I don't know if I
want to do dungeon the drag I don't
really know anything about it and my
nephew had asked to come over to play
the game with my house when I watched
him play The Joy of it you don't have to
know anything about dragons or anything
about the world it's just play how do
you think the film represents the game
we've had a lot of you know very
die-hard fans watch it and it seems like
we've found a bit of resonance there
Friday kids joyful it's fun it's
frustrating it's sad it's all the feels
you know I'm a planner he connected with
his character edgin a charismatic Thief
who is never short on wit so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot Hogan not relevant is a the world's
greatest actor and liar so I think I
hold a lot in common with with uh with
good old egg only answer when I talk to
you okay I think a lot of people see
themselves in this film you have one
character Olga who lost her family you
have my character who lost his family
and the idea of Desiring company and
family and friendship and Community is
very human and I think that's really at
the heart of our film oh God I could
kiss you try it again along with his
best friend holga played by Michelle
Rodriguez go on a mission seeking
Redemption from his daughter and revenge
against a friend turned foe played by
Hugh Grant I don't see you die which is
why I'm Gonna Leave the room I imagine
it had to be somewhat liberating
being the guy and having this badass
woman come to the rescue well I mean
look I grew up in a family of very
strong women
now that is not a new experience for me
Pine grew up in Los Angeles with his
actress mother Gwen and his father
Robert who starred on the popular TV
series chips what I'll say about my
parents both is that I grew up in an
intensely creative environment they
certainly were wary of me going down the
path because
it's a tough road but once I once I was
into it they supported me wholeheartedly
what Admiral's daughter that support has
led to a number of Hollywood
Blockbusters and reboots as Captain Kirk
in the Star Trek Trilogy I'm a spy
and Steve Trevor in Wonder Woman while
playing a leading man seems to run in
his blood Pine is ready to prove he can
do it all you've directed your first
feature film pool man which you also
co-wrote you star in you produce it as
well it was so much fun yeah
I can't even tell you to be in a scene
with Annette betting wow you know is
kind of a thrill to be like in really in
it with her you know at 42 Pine says
he's all about living in the moment now
well how do we pull that off uh figure
it out over a drink probably best what
I'm trying to do is really follow my joy
I'm looking to be inspired again and
like his loot playing barred character
Edgar he puts his talents and humor to
good use anything you want to add
I'm good well you know what might
inspire you is
this is a full-on like oh my gosh
there's too many strings on that
instrument 8 10 12 16 17. I had four
strings
[Music]
not trying to I am
you're being
for CBS mornings I'm Natalie Morales in
Los Angeles
insane now we all know what a loot is
yeah yeah he's built very likable that
Christmas the elite in movies yes he is
he just has the look and the talent this
is going to be a massive film I mean
like Dungeons and Dragons came out in
the 70s as a role-playing game but it's
it's having a moment huge following
they're like storefronts dedicated to it
now uh the film Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves is a film by
Paramount Pictures division of our
parent company the movie hits theaters
tomorrow see it there we'll be right
back